this is a production of cornell
university
yeah uh well well as always thanks to
our live audience for you guys
uh listening or watching on youtube
thanks for watching this is the 11th
episode of our cornell turf show this
year
uh more than halfway through our spring
series uh today's guest dr sean askew
virginia tech weed scientist uh we'll
talk about a lot of things with sean
we may have some spontaneous rapping on
the show sean is a
accomplished musician we may talk or may
not see that later on we'll see
um but as always we'll start the show
off with frank rossi giving us a little
bit of a
weather overview and some uh cool little
tidbits from the last week we've seen
hey yeah
thanks carl hi everybody and thanks
again to sean for joining us
all of you either watching live uh or or
uh watching a recording or listening on
a podcast uh
if you're getting to watch it you see
this uh you know little baby face here
uh announcing probably the most exciting
uh golf time of the year for a lot of us
in the golf business
uh the masters um and
and of course it continues the the
the routine of family members getting
out and working
and this superintendent was bragging on
his daughter uh
cutting lasers uh on on the greens in
the morning but
i'd have to say by far the thing that
actually choked me up when i saw it
was uh matsuyama's caddy uh
dropping it in and bow into the course
so uh
you know for guys like us this doesn't
get any better than that now with that
carl
let me get to the bmp of the week with
you uh just to remind everybody this
is a project underway with the new york
state pollution prevention institute
that's housed at the rochester institute
of technology
that gets its funding from the
department of environmental conservation
and we have partnered with them to work
on
uh adoption and uptake of the bmps
and there's a website you can go to sign
up
get more information but today carl we
got you
in this lovely grin on your face
promoting our poster
and so what's the tip of the day yeah so
so frank a lot of times we talk about
protecting water quality and we think
about the fertilizer we apply in the
golf course
the pesticides application pesticide
applications we make but
really our wash pad areas are a source
of
point source pollution we can call it
but a singular source
a place where we might see a lot of
times the grass clippings that you wash
off of equipment
the oil residues that come off there and
pesticide residue
sediment and a lot of times we see those
situated near water bodies so
we have some some points on this poster
that address things you can do to
to reduce the amount of water that you
use at a wash pad facility and also
maybe to help with water quality
um and so some of these things reducing
just the amount of water you use
goes a long way just changing the hose
nozzle right and there's this little
brass hose nozzle we got here that
that our friend rich flattery former
superintendent of locust hill country
club found uh works really well it's 10
bucks you could pick it up at a
a hardware store and it reduces your
water use on wash pads by
50 right so that's one really easy thing
switch in switch out
get a cheap nozzle uh that can help you
reduce
the amount of water and then uh you know
another thing you can do is just blow
equipment off before you wash it with
with uh
whether that's a backpack blower a
pressurized air blower
um you know not only does that
significantly again reduce
water use by about 50 but hey your
mechanic might thank you right we're not
we're not using so much water all over
the
equipment maybe you get a little less
rest a little less wear and tear
and then one thing you can do if you're
going to use those tools to reduce water
use how about you measure it too
and this is just attaching another uh
flow meter again you know 50 75 bucks
pick this up somewhere
know how much you use and then you know
what let's let's look at that cart barn
too right you guys are watching
equipment
uh i the the standard image in my head
frank i worked in in a cart barn
is you just got a kid who's just
pointing the hose and just on his phone
and spraying it right so
you know maybe it's a good thing if
you're concerned about water use
especially moving into the future where
we may start paying a lot more
for water thinking more judiciously
about using water
let's think about how much water we use
on the wash pad and think about ways to
reduce that
and i'm telling you carl the other thing
that you put in each slide about the
card barn is
worth noting because not only are we
obviously trying to conserve water in
many places
uh but we're also being there's a
greater demand for water carts are being
washed uh
more frequently now and i think it's
just good
knowledge to know hey how much did our
water use go up during the pandemic how
much of our water use gone up since
we've gone to
single cart people right and and are we
can we clean them a different way
that's not as reliant on uh on using
potable water and of course carl you're
the you're the expert with those
card bar and bnps that one of these days
you're going to see the light of day
we'll see one day one day maybe all
right all right so let's get to the
grown grass
part that that i tell you that some of
these low-hanging fruits and the bmps
uh big thanks to carl and everybody rick
slattery everybody helps us put these
together
uh and we're gonna be out and about
talking about these more but for now
the story is play and traffic and people
want to get out there and
you know you learned this morning that
the average temperatures
uh really at this time of the year for
our you know the northeast is
between the mid 50s and the mid 60s and
so it's been much warmer than normal
over the last several weeks which has
given us this false sense and
the growing season has really pushed now
doug soldat
tweeted out a really interesting picture
uh last week also about how
phosphorus deficiency is showing up
where he's putting on
more fertilizer where he's getting more
growth in places where he had low
or very little phosphorus he was seeing
no deficiency symptoms now
that's just a small aspect of the way
plants manage and and and and show
uh nutrient deficiencies but i think we
also see a lot of people worried about
bent grass turning red poa turning red
at this time of the year or the bent
grass especially
you know is it red leaf spot or whatever
and i would say in general
i think we're hearing most of the time
it's just a little bit of phosphorus
deficiency or uptake stuff
look at your growth rates right now of
course we're all pushing our growth
rates these days
just to keep up with the traffic now i
think when you talk about growth rates
and how things are moving along and
coming together you start to focus on
the soil temperatures
and you can see now we've changed the
scale down here at the bottom
where the majority of us now are in the
upper 40s and 50s right
obviously as you get down to where dr
askew is it's quite a bit warmer soil
conditions and south jersey and delmarva
the philly area and then when you get
into the new york metropolitan area
you're talking about pretty steady
early low to mid 50. so things are
really accelerating it's going to be
interesting moving forward
a lot of guys taking advantage maybe
trying to do some verification
you know the funny thing is we get these
greens in perfect shape
and then we can go do this to them i
keep wondering about this but
we'll hold this for another day maybe
when we can get my power rocker soi on
and talk to him about the the problems
with early spring air vacation
now the season has definitely advanced
very rapidly
you can see a buffalo and rochester
in particular down in the metro new york
area
everybody is pretty generally a week to
two weeks ahead of normal now
you can accumulate uh growing degree
days base 50
pretty rapidly at this time of year
that's why we use base 32
uh for the seed head discussion that
we're going to have later
over the course of the over the morning
here so so
what is coming up well you can look at
one way to visualize this pretty much
from here
to the 21st uh next week we're going to
be below
normal right we've got a high percentage
of being below normal
um it's particularly for most of the
northeast maybe
up into maine you know where the five
people who live in maine up here with
robert searle
uh are listening uh they may get a
little bit
above normal but most of us are going to
be a little bit cooler
um and then when it comes to rainfall
there was a couple of big winners this
past week but most again
we're on the you know mid to three half
to three quarters of an inch was pretty
widespread
across the region and the outlook is
looking for a little more rain along the
coast
so certainly coastally you can expect
some rain uh
over the next week anyway now the topic
for today with my esteemed colleague
is annual bluegrass right and
particularly this aspect of annual
bluegrass
growth and development that continues to
plague us now
we have done everything we can over the
years to try to target these early
spring applications both with embark and
prox
but i want to go back a little bit
probably even before dr
ask you might have even been born you
guys young weed scientists are so great
nowadays
that back in the early 80s there was a
scientist rich cooper
from ohio was doing this work with tony
coskey
when they were graduate students at the
ohio state work
university worker for john street this
is the original work with
embark that looked at seed head
suppression right annual bluegrass seed
head suppression
so one of the first things that came out
of this particular study
was that when you sprayed the medium or
or high rate of
embark right here's no embark
low rate medium and high rate you look
at the data of
total non-structural carbohydrates which
is a measure of the stored energy
that a plant might have available to us
both in
soluble sugars and long-chain uh
long-chain
uh storage storage uh compounds like
fructose and starch in
in warm season grasses right so then
they looked at root elongation
they also found you know a long time ago
that that high rates of embark uh or
even medium rates of embark
were really accelerating route
elongation
uh compared to control certainly the
high rate hit
now the other thing that this paper
noted uh
is that the content of uh carbohydrate
content while it
increased while it increased uh
when you suppress the seed heads it then
depleted after the fact because this was
the
early indication of the rebound effect
right this was our first
identification of the rebound effect
that of course is
served as the basis for a lot of growing
degree day models that are used and why
we use them
and then along came doctor asked you and
asked the question what if we applied
these things
uh later in the season and particularly
winter in the
mid-atlantic where uh dr askew was based
he saw immediately
that seed head suppression when you
added that winter application
winter and spring was certainly better
than spring by itself
now zack riker goes to work from bear
puts together a national look at this
thing right this was a i just found this
recently shown
that this paper was done and of course
you were on it with many of our
colleagues johnny guigiado here in
connecticut
and here are the application timings for
this fall
application of proxy now remember the
research i showed you was based on
fluidized but that's been pretty much
replaced both because
people had a hard time figuring out how
to use it and they stopped making
so proxy became the go-to compound
that also wasn't as hard necessarily on
adjacent
uh plants that might have been treated
now here's the crazy data that again for
those of you watching on
news channel six can hone in on this
we'll just take it really simple and go
to the
connecticut data right so here is
untreated and you can see lots of lots
of room
under the seed head cover progress curve
right
how much seed heads we were able
actually to
suppress so the pretty standard spring
applications of proxy and primo
for those of you watching is in red and
then anything that had a fall
application is in yellow gray or blue
yellow gray or blue and you can see in
general
in general we continue to see
this uh improvement in seed head
suppression and i would
i would venture to say consistency i
think one of the things i've noticed
about these fall application zones is
they're they're a lot
more consistently giving you suppression
and i think sometimes people
uh overestimate how well things didn't
work
you know we used to get 40 suppression
if we got lucky
in the spring 50 percent if we got lucky
and we
you know beat the band how great that
was so i think the fall applications
have definitely i think brought some
more consistency so let's
talk about this a little bit a little
bit with three simple questions
are we seeing better suppression in the
fall uh do we get what is your thoughts
about i don't expect you to have the
research so i'm kind of asking you to
speculate here
about health benefits compared to embark
music proxy
and how much does uh we'll get to the
point carl was bringing up before i
uh jumped on how much does annual
bluegrass seed head
stuff uh impact putting so with that i'm
gonna stop
sharing uh and i'm going to look at you
and we'll start with how well are these
fall things working
everywhere and in particular we're here
in the northeast for us
all right so thanks for having me on
frank
and first of all the the concept behind
this fall
application deal is that it has to do
with trying it's something that we don't
really know
uh it has to do with how is ethefon
inhibiting seed head development and
certainly i would
surmise that what ethiphone is doing
is different from what my fluidite was
doing all right and so ethevon is acting
much more like a hormone
in that it is affecting the
uh the decision of the plant whether or
not it will make a seed head and
unfortunately
there's who knows there's four or five
other hormones many of them
environmentally induced
that are doing the same thing so all of
these and this is me
kind of speculating on what we think we
know in the literature
okay don't worry sean nobody's listening
nobody's watching
it's just uh anyway so the idea is that
at the fine is an influencer
among several influencers so as your
environment changes
from one winter season spring season to
the next
all these influencers are competing if
you get ethephone
out in the spring who are you
influencing
you're only going to influence the
plants that have not yet decided to make
a seed head
and so the premise is if you put at the
fawn out in the fall and in the spring
you maintain
a strong level of influence from that
ethylene
escalation that's happening when you
apply ethathon
so that even if you have a rogue warm
day in the winter
you have that fall base application to
continue to signal to the plants don't
make a seed head don't make a seed head
don't make a c day even if there are
environmental cues it says no
make a seed man what are you thinking
this time right the ethaphon is saying
don't make a seed ed these things are
competing
and i and i one thing that i've noticed
in our research
we always see phenomenal effects
of this fall versus spring thing and we
also see phenomenal we're talking 90
plus percent seeded suppression
i don't see those c debt suppression
levels on in play golf courses
do you honestly that's because of timing
or do you think that's because you might
only have one
bio type or do you think it's a little
bit of both the the lingering question
is sean
what you started with something we don't
know have you done or is the annual
bluegrass national annual bluegrass
project working at all and trying to
figure out what are the keys to flower
in initiation that you may be hitting
that many other guys i honestly
so we're not looking at sea dead
suppression per se in that national
program we're looking more at herbicide
resistance
and what i can say and we're not really
looking at pgrs factor vicious all is
one of the products
but a lot of the researchers have kind
of shied away from it because there's
not a base
line uh you know expectation
for resistance and paclo is a product
that
utilizes environmental stress
as a cohort to try to achieve
displacement of annual bluegrass you
don't just spray paclo
and kill annual bluegrass so how do you
test resistance
right and so it's a lot more complicated
than the the protocol they first
designed for this
for this project and
we don't really we're not getting
outstanding information about
how pgrs are influencing the poem but at
virginia tech we we did kind of up the
ante on paclo
and we did we are seeing a lot of
mechanisms or at least we're seeing
several populations that were responding
quite differently to paclo than
other populations and honestly believe
that what's happening with ethaphon and
seaded suppression on golf courses
is probably more due to the fact that
ethiphon
has been used repeatedly on many of
these golf courses and therefore
we've already found the super sensitive
biotypes
and they haven't been able to make seed
for a decade
and they're not there and so you know
whereas at tech
i can get 90 control on a given golf
course that's used at the fawn for
eight to ten years or more they can't
and i think it's
due to some level of resistance that's
built up now not to say
not in the classical sense i'm not
saying that oh well ethon doesn't work
or proxy doesn't work at your course
anymore because you got resistance it's
not quite like that
but i do think that the response of the
population
is a bit muted compared to a population
that's never seen
so so so what you're suggesting this is
very
interesting what you're suggesting is
chronic use
that does a good job of suppressing seed
heads
uh of a particular type that might be
prevalent in a location
over time because that seed bank
is depleted because if there's new
recruits
you know so that begs the next question
how come or do does proxy in your mind
lead to a healthier annual bluegrass
plant
that like embark did and
therefore you're you're getting is that
reducing
fitness in some way well that so the
ethaphon
along with other like primo and the
things that we do to manage
culturally manage our greens do cater to
polar survival environmental stress
fights that
and you know we kind of want to lose
polar in in many
most cases uh but we don't want to lose
it rapidly we want to lose it slowly
and so but we're managing to maintain a
putting surface above all
else and therefore pola just rides along
and gets the benefits from that
and yes when we inhibit seed head
production just like was shown with the
carbohydrate changes with um a fluidized
we inhibit the plant from spending
massive amounts of stored energy to make
those seed
and so the ability to preserve that
stored
energy gives those plants the ability to
make all of the environmental fighting
things that they need to manage stress
later in the season as they start to
experience the stress now if you
contrast that with
not using a seed suppressor and having
copious amounts of seed heads being
produced daily literally daily we're
mowing off
new seed production with oils and fatty
acids and we're talking high energy
stuff
daily and then what happens the plant
starts to turn
yellow as soon as the first hint of warm
weather
and they'll start to die out right
because they have literally
they've given it everything they've got
and that's what they're designed to do
that's what an annual plant is designed
to do it's designed to give it
everything it's got
put all of the energy into that
endosperm of those seed
and then die and then their their their
longevity is based on that seed
production and with pola
i mean they can get in and fit in
anywhere right and so that's how they're
designed
so we we take out that energy production
and we leave those existing plants more
but let's get back to the proxy thing
and the resistance
so poa is primarily even though we
manage and we've actually
produced phenotypes of perennial plants
pola is an annual plant and even on
greens a large percentage even of our
highly managed which results in high
percentage of perennial
highly managed greens we still have a
lot of annual pola
well which one of them's produced seed
the ones that ethiphon
is not as active on so we are there's no
way we can't be selecting for
phenotypes within that population that
are less susceptible
to po to ethiphon or it might be
there's so many mechanisms that could be
at play here it could be that they're
more susceptible to the environmental
cues that say make a seed head
so they don't hear the ethiphone okay so
this this raises a question to me that
you must ask yourself when we start when
you started this thing is
yeah i know when i studied pre-emergent
applications of crabgrass stuff in the
fall the first question i got is well
what happens if my grass dies in the
winter
and i need to seed in the spring how
concerned were you
and what do you see of maybe a negative
effect
of applying a growth regulator at that
time of the year which is odd right so
most guys are applying it with their
snowmobile right most places that's
almost recommended
but when you are imagining this have you
seen any downside to that fall app
relative to
sort of setback of the poet if you've
got pure polar surfaces like a lot of
guys do here
right my biggest fear was for for you
folks like in northern new york and
extremely cold climates any climate
where
in the winter it's possible to lose pola
because of winter stress
that's not my environment you know we we
get severe winters but the longevity and
the you know we don't get ice cover and
snow cover for long periods we don't
even
our guys put down snow mode but but not
every year it's only if they really
expect so
it's not same environment but we were
keen to look at
any indicator of that in our research
even though i don't have the extreme
environment that you guys would have to
truly test it
and i haven't seen anything that really
suggests that amping up your ethifon
program with winter apps or fall apps
some people are doing fall
and winter apps followed by spring apps
um
what i often see associated with poe
injury from ethefond is
in the spring if you're getting
intermittent frost events
and ethaphon is on the ground we'll see
pola
you know turn yellow turn orange but i
don't really see
i haven't seen that type of effect
during
harsh winter conditions i see the same
level of you know your reddening and
the red tips things that would be caused
by a cold temperature induced phosphorus
availability issue those things are
fairly uniform in the non-treated as
well as in the ethiopian treaty we don't
really see
i haven't seen an indication that the
ethiphone is going to
um reduce winter survival but i haven't
had the environment to test it okay one
more question on this uh stuff with
plant health things because we get these
lingering
uh early season anthracnose uh
infections sean
uh you know where guys might use the
fall app on their greens
because they've had some success but as
you know you've talked about there's a
lot of variables involved with this plan
it's
you know it's not a sort of
straightforward deal it adapts adjusts
we don't understand how it's doing it we
have a lot of issues with guys who push
their greens have to push their greens
later into the season
it's not really a winner thing it's more
just man
approach regulations from this then they
got dmis that they're putting on for
summer patch stuff then they might use a
pre-post
a pre-crab goose application right the
the oxidized on benzelide combination
and we've talked about this in the show
so far this year i'm wondering what your
thoughts are about how proxy adds or
helps
to that sort of early season regulation
issue and if that isn't some of the
problems
that we see happening when polar starts
to fail
well i don't i don't think proxy is
going to help
and i've actually designed and conducted
studies looking at your 90 gdd
early dollar spot program with dmis and
i've thrown all those things into the
system to try to see what comes out the
other end and
i haven't really seen anything with the
limited work that i'm able to do
and an environment environment that i
have so no i haven't seen indications
that proxy's heating things up or
really stirring the pot in a bad way
when it comes to all of these additives
i think it's a matter of managing your
environmental stress
and just knowing that if you put a
growth regulator like epiphone or if you
put a growth regulating dmi down
you're not helping so it's a matter of
you know in your
your shaded areas your weak areas it's
just a matter of keeping a keen eye
on how they're going to respond to
whatever that challenge is
and knowing that you're not helping
that problem by adding these so
so then it's you know it's a you're
weighing your need for c dead
suppression against
a risk over here and and you just have
to balance but it's interesting i want
to ask you this last question about
playability carl kill me if i don't
catch you on this
in a minute but what you just described
is really fascinating
because within a green you might have a
shade or a high traffic area
that maybe that's where you shut the
boom off or if you you go at a lower
rate
or you you know whatever and i think
that's the kind of site-specific
management again
that we've got to start thinking about
and this is of course another example of
it oh that's 100 a mental thing too
i see the one that drives me nuts are
athletic field managers
you have a multiplex and you know it's
three or four
fields together and there's
very measurable and repeatable high wear
spots
on these fields but the vast majority of
it is like in between area where people
set up their lawn chairs and stuff and
and that could get a pre-emerge we could
put a root inhibiting pre on
60 70 percent of that area as long as
you don't put it on the highway areas
but nobody seems to have that concept in
their head of zones
because we didn't train them this right
and it wasn't so easy to not do it in
the past and i think you're right we
talk about this all the time in sports
fields okay
so now how i know you've done the work
with bent
and poe spots that shows the deflection
and those interesting could go listen to
our wonderful podcast episode that's
one of the most listened to ones we've
ever done
i'm interested in the other side of this
does
where we got a lot of pulp and you get
some power seeds and some poe doesn't
see
would you expect the same kind of
trouble
in putting uh like you know in that
situation because
i i'm perplexed by why they complain
about poet in the pacific northwest
and the southern california where they
torri pines and
bumpy poets all you hear out here and
then they come to wingfoot and they they
don't they think it's bankgrass and it's
100 full annual
how do you reconcile the impact of the
way we think about poe's effect on
putting performance
so in our ballroom work very few
of the poor patches had seed heads and
if they did have seed heads it was at a
time
of year where it was a bit later in the
season the seed heads were
mostly diminished like so we would have
a clump that in prime seed head
production would have had say 250
seed heads on it when we did our work
there may have been five
so seeds weren't a major contributor
when we did our work and it was on
both of the golf courses where we did
where we selected multiple greens were
pretty high in
the management the way we like to
describe it if you close your eyes
we can leave you there all day you will
not find that polar plant you're not
going to be able to feel it
but when you open your eyes you can see
that there is a textural difference i
just don't know that the human hand
could have picked it up
so outside of seed heads just talking
about poa
what's the deal with ball roll i would
say i i could sum it up as
as simply as this the higher
the um the difference between
bent and pole composition gets the worse
your ball roll is going to be
so as you move to a predominantly polar
system
your ball rolls going your consistency
of role is going to improve
as you move to a predominantly bent
system your consistency is going to
improve
but where you have where you're rolling
across
poa and you encounter a zone of bent
i would expect a deviation there uh
either the bent density
is going to be low enough that the ball
is going to sink in more and when it
comes back out on the other side like a
wave it's going to hit that pola
uh and i'm i'm magnitude i'm i'm
increasing the magnitude of the actual
effects for
we're talking microscopic effects but
it's enough
once that slight bounce has been created
and when the ball starts to bounce when
it comes back into the canopy it plows
into the canopy and now
density changes in the canopy can steer
it a little bit left or a little bit
right
and so when you transition from pola to
bent to poet event that's where you have
problems if you're all poe you're good
if you're all bent you're good john what
a joy
carl we're at 30 minutes but i want i
don't want to leave without
letting you uh bring up the stat of you
know
putting later in the day uh the leaders
can you talk to ask sean about that
particular stat
well well so you know there's we have
the shot link data now sean
and there's these people on twitter who
analyze all this data and
and look at when players play during the
day what is their strokes game what's
their putting performance like basically
and once you normalize for a player's
ability and look at the mtm
they see yeah although it's a it's only
a microscopic little bit
they put worse in the afternoons than in
the mornings
uh i don't think that's revolutionary to
us uh you know
if you could speculate quickly on what
you think might cause that is it the
growth changes
is it the traffic uh influence of all
that
normally on the green any anomaly on the
green is going to be magnified
with growth so if it's a differential
between pola and ben that differential
is going to be greater the
the further away from mowing you get if
it's a ball mark
the differential between the perimeter
of the ball mark and the ball mark
itself is going to be the greatest the
further away from the mowing you get
and so i i think even if it's a let's
say
it's a pythium root uh issue that's
causing a regulation of
of a pure bent green and pole has
nothing to do with it
then the fact that part of that green is
not growing as effectively and the other
is you're going to have the highest
degree of difference between density and
you know that could steer the ball the
further away from mowing that you get
and i and yes so their data i think is
biologically real and the only way we'd
be able to see it is by taking that
massive amounts of data
and showing how look at here there's a
slight change in their performance
later in the day yes i think it's a it's
magnifying
these differences that are that truly
are on the green but they are of such
subtle influence
it took me and my student a year and a
half two years tens of thousands of
balls
just to control variability enough to
start to measure
yeah yeah and for those interested
there's great papers on this right carl
we
we've done deep dives on this a few
times we're at the witching hour sean
let me thank you for joining us
really appreciate you taking the time
particularly on short notice carl
uh we could talk to this guy all day but
we better let everybody get back to work
yeah we'll get everybody back uh thanks
everybody for joining i did post the the
podcast
uh that frank and sean did a year ago
talking a little bit more in depth about
some of this stuff
uh they also talk about a poet cure a
product that may help you if you're in
that kind of 50 bent 50 poa
range you know getting further to one
side or the other maybe that's
an interesting conversation for you to
check out so thanks everybody for
joining uh
tomorrow's webinar we'll have matt
elmore on from rutgers university
talking about some weed season
early sweet seed uh issues and
until then we'll see you guys later see
you guys later
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu